foreign
although Nuremberg is a feature of
living memory there are people alive
today many of them who were around to
see that trial and its aftermath it is
somehow distant enough it is 76 years
ago that the trial of the doctors
concluded 1947
that people do not have the relationship
with Nuremberg that they need to have
and I wanted to both point out what the
Nuremberg code is why it matters why it
is above law why it has a status in our
in our ethics Paradigm that is above law
and what that therefore means to see a
multiple violation of Nuremberg in the
present right what what reaction should
we be having to to that simple fact
so
let's start with some Basics there were
two Nuremberg trials and a historian may
have a better view on this than I do I
welcome any refinements or corrections
but there were two trials there was a
general trial
um for Nazis who were captured
and there was a doctor's trial because
the medical violations were were a
unique and profound fact of the
Holocaust
and
there's no
gentle way to say this
we literally hung seven doctors over
violations of informed consent which as
far as I understand it was not
formalized in advance of the Holocaust
right so the point is this was
understood to be a principle that any
rational doctor should Intuit
right and in fact the Nuremberg Trial of
the doctors was an extension of the
Hippocratic Oath every doctor swears to
the Hippocratic Oath if you have sworn
to the Hippocratic oath to First Do no
harm then that has a direct
extrapolation to Medical experiments
that the doctors who engaged in the
behavior that the Nazi doctors engaged
in were understood to have violated
implicitly to the point that they were
executed publicly right that is an
amazing statement that that is not 500
years ago that's 76 years ago we
literally hung seven doctors because
they violated informed consent which was
not yet codified it became codified in
as a result of Nuremberg and it is now
something that no doctor can even though
Nuremberg declared it not an excuse that
you didn't know about this you now can
be held responsible for violating the
Nuremberg code because it has been
spelled out and enumerated yeah there's
there's even less reason to imagine that
you can escape culpability now post
Nuremberg Nuremberg was a specifically
predicated on the Hippocratic Oath this
you know this principle that goes back a
couple thousand years in medicine that
one should first Do no harm which is of
course easy to say and then in practice
you know obviously a surgeon does harm
so it means something like do not net
harm or do not foreseeable net harm or
something like that yeah you can't take
an instantaneous measure of like at no
point uh in inflict something that could
be harmful like that's that that can't
be what it means and so it does require
um
the ability for doctors to make
decisions right and to take risks which
is also why it is an oath and not a rule
yeah right oath means you are going to
agree to this principle this value and
then you are going to figure out how it
applies to what you are doing right this
is above law right that's really
important there is Law and then there
are things that are above law it's a
higher authority it is a higher
authority and it is putting you in a
position of doing the interpretation in
real time it may be an emergency right
you may be trying to figure out you know
do I cut this person's leg off even
though this person might survive if I
left the leg intact you know you
juggling it is is the key thing that a
doctor is trained to do
and the Nuremberg judges there were
three
in the doctor's trial the Nuremberg
judges
understood the oath to imply informed
consent
they then ruled that these seven doctors
were guilty of such egregious violations
of that principle that they were
literally hung which I find
barbaric frankly the idea that we hung
these people but my point is this was an
act this was an extraordinary
um tragedy
that
was dealt with by civilization with
extraordinary responses because of the
profundity of all of the principles
involved
and to find ourselves in
the 2020s
casually facing violations of those very
same principles and the deeper you dig
the more obvious it becomes how many
violations there are I thought it was
two informed consent we didn't consent
because we were mandated and we weren't
informed because they shut down the free
exchange of ideas that's two violations
but then I looked at all the sub
Provisions in the Nuremberg in the
Nuremberg code and it's
it's stunning yeah you want to put that
up and actually I'm going to read the
first paragraph and then we can quickly
just look at some of these and you'll
spot immediately how covid maps onto
this thing it's it's incredible
so the Nuremberg code provision one so
just um what you're showing here is an
article a review 50 years after the
Nuremberg code published in the New
England Journal of Medicine in which a
piece from the original code is um
published yes the original code is
republished and then there's historical
context presented
the voluntary consent of the human
subject is absolutely essential period
this means that the person involved
should have Lee should have legal
capacity to give consent should be so
situated as to be able to exercise free
Power of Choice without the intervention
of any element of force fraud deceit
duress overreaching or other ulterior
form of constraint or coercion so if you
think the mandates don't violate this
because they didn't carry the force of
law they were certainly coercive it
continues and should have sufficient
knowledge and comprehension of the
elements of the subject matter involved
to enable him to make an understanding
and enlightened decision
this latter element requires that before
the acceptance of an affirmative
decision by the experimental subject
there should be made known to him the
nature duration and purpose of the
experiment
the method and means by which it is to
be conducted all inconveniences and
Hazards reasonably to be expected and
the effects upon his health or person
which may possibly come from this
participation in the experiment the duty
and responsibility for ascertaining the
quality of the consent rests upon each
individual who initiates directs or
engages in the experiment that is not
the subjects it is the personal Duty and
responsibility which may not be
delegated to another with impunity and
that last phrase is interesting it may
not be delicated to someone who cannot
be punished that's what that means right
Pfizer was immunized it cannot be
punished it cannot be it cannot have
delegated to it the responsibility for
informed consent which it then falls
down on and is somehow immune to being
prosecuted that is not acceptable
according to the Nuremberg code
which I find amazing this is so clear
right when mapped onto
the mandates for these experimental
treatments is
absolutely Unforgivable
and when I say unforgivable I'm talking
about a code that preceded the hanging
of seven doctors so I mean Unforgivable
all right provision two the experiment
should be such as to yield fruitful
results for the good of society
unprocurable by other methods or means
of study and not random and unnecessary
in nature right the experiment has to be
justified on the basis that harm done
would be in the service of a greater
good that's what that means so and and
this second item in the Nuremberg code
that the experiment should be
unprocurable by other methods or means
of study
Maps very neatly on to the conditions
for which you can get granted an eua
absolutely an emergency use
authorization which as we discussed in
gosh it's going to be early 2021 with
regard to the suppression of uh the use
of ivermectin in the treatment of covid
it was necessary that there be no other
treatment for covid that was available
else
Pfizer and moderna could not have gotten
euas for these experimental treatments
that they cleverly sneakily falsely
called vaccines
uh which means that the suppression of
information on hydroxychloroquine on
Ivermectin and on vitamin D is another
violation of Nuremberg right
um all right three the experiment should
be so designed and based on the results
of animal experimentation and a
knowledge of the natural history of the
disease
and or and other problem understudy that
the anticipated results will justify the
performance of The Experiment
so they obscured the natural history of
the disease itself and they could not
possibly have appropriately used animals
in the testing well it's interesting
actually so this three here is reminds
me a little bit of our constitution
Nuremberg code is obviously much younger
than the American Constitution but there
are places and we've talked about this a
lot There Are Places the American
Constitution that as amazing and
forward-thinking and Brilliant as our
founding fathers of this country were
they could not have foreseen some of the
technological advances that were to come
hundreds of years in the future
this
um this phrase that the experiment
should be based on the results it should
include a knowledge of the natural
history of the disease
belies the fact that they could not
foresee that we might buy at some at
some point in the future be creating
Franken viruses right and so you know
fully aside from like oh they're
obscuring they're still claiming this is
zoonotic origin they're still looking
for you know stuff in the animal Market
all of this
it's actually not going to be possible
three won't be possible in a world that
has already allowed the kind of gain of
function research that almost certainly
produced SARS Kobe 2 in the first place
which means that the research might be
understood to be itself in violation of
Nuremberg that's a good point and at the
very least it is an absolute obligation
not to obscure the origin because as we
said here on Dark Horse we're at what I
have heard nowhere else that what was
done the protocols that were deployed
that created the virus have implications
for how you might expect it to evolve
Downstream and what you might want to do
to treat it and prevent it so we had a
right to that information and they
obscured it violating yet another
provision of the Nuremberg code
four the experiment should be so
conducted as to avoid all unnecessary
physical and mental suffering and injury
gee the denial of natural immunity and
the immunizing of people who were too
young and healthy to be vulnerable to
this disease cannot be justified and
some of them were harmed so that was
unnecessary physical and mental
suffering and injury for sure it was and
I mean there was also a lot of playing
so much of what was accomplished was
done through slights of hand slights of
language in fact right and so call it a
vaccine you're not an anti-vaxxer are
you well what if I say among other
things my objection to that is that that
thing that you're calling a vaccine
isn't a vaccine now it's a vaccine we
said it was and so it was also
experimental in nature it was brand new
and the this mRNA technology as we've
talked about extensively as many people
have was was brand new and up until that
point there had not been any successful
this successful research in humans and
there hadn't been for this product
either but we just kind of like you know
threw the dice and
it wasn't ever called to us those who
were told we must take this thing and
experiment and so the language of
Nuremberg is an experiment what it has
been recognized as is an experimental
treatment right and uh we will get later
at the end of the hour to um to other
sort of squidgy words that are used to
obscure that fact but you can call it
everything anything you want it doesn't
change the fact that you were
experimenting on humans well with this
treatment that was called a vaccine not
only that but because of the way that
this was accelerated and then deployed
globally you were dealing with I think
it is phase four right there are three
three of the uh the safety trials
right that is to say in release of the
uh the stuff into use in the public
there is then the intense monitoring of
signals of Adverse Events right that is
understood formally as part of an
experiment
and in this case you know what I've said
before is this was an experiment in
every way but one which is that we did
not seek to collect the data that would
have made it a valid scientific
experiment immoral but at least
scientifically valid but if you're going
to obscure the evidence of a harm then
you know you're you're deliberately not
looking at the results of the experiment
you're running
um and then you know of course
unnecessary physical and mental
suffering and injury
what the hell the gaslighting of the
injured is
to me the most jaw-dropping fact of the
whole thing right that you would take
people especially people you know Maddie
to Gary who a child who participated in
your safety trial because she wanted to
do her part to address covid is Gravely
injured and then you pretend that she's
not that she's faking like what kind of
diabolical monster would you have to be
to do that right and yet we saw it
across the board there's still
gaslighting the injured and that is
unnecessary physical and mental
suffering and injury as outlined in
provision 4 of the Nuremberg code which
again we hung seven doctors over so I
guess um
at some level I wonder
I do think I was naive as a child to
think that never again was
was important and necessary but it would
never really happen here because I this
was Nuremberg was 1947 you said yeah the
doctors trial the doctor's child
concluded included in 47. so I'm
thinking about the Tuskegee syphilis
experiments yep right they began I just
looked it up in the early 30s
but they continued well past 1947 and in
fact apparently it was in 1947 that
um uh
was it um
syphilis I think I found this I can't
say oh yes
um penicillin became the recommended
treatment for syphilis in 1947. WoW
same year as the the doctor's trial the
Nuremberg
code
became reified so
Nuremberg happens and syphilis becomes
the recommended treatment for syphilis
the same year penicillin sorry
penicillin becomes the what did I say if
it doesn't work no it really doesn't
Okay so let's start over
um
the normal code becomes reified and
penicillin becomes the recommended the
understood to be an effective treatment
against syphilis both in 1947. 15 years
into the this into the Diabolical
Tuskegee experiments in which
um Southern black men are allowed to get
sick and die from syphilis uh and
deliberately not treated deliberately
not treated and not told and you know it
is it is a you know it is a
it is such an obvious example of a lack
of informed consent that it is the thing
that everyone has some recognition of
Tuskegee you know brings up that you
know these experiments just the way
Nuremberg brings up the code even though
Tuskegee and nurburg are places that
don't that presumably other people live
in and you know would like to be
recognized for other things but so the
Tuskegee experiments continued for
decades into like the 70s yeah right
decades early 70s I believe
um after after both the Nuremberg code
and there is a known simple powerful
antibiotic that does treat the very
thing
so given that
why are we in fact surprised well that
that Nuremberg was violated perhaps
across every single
the tenant
right during covet here's why okay
I have never heard anyone defend
Tuskegee
right okay I've never heard it okay but
but so the end it ended and I don't know
exactly like early 70s so 50 50 years
ago right yeah 50 years from now
well that's my 50 50 years from now if
if we haven't managed to disappear
ourselves from the planet
50 years from now
the prediction is
no one
will be defending what happened that is
here that is exactly offending it and
the vast majority of people who were
gleefully shaming those of us who were
trying to speak up for Science and for
truth and for Humanity
they will have either largely died or
pretended they you know they will have
pretended that that wasn't really their
position they will talk about how
honorable and upstanding they were in
fighting the fight when they are
absolutely lying like no one will
acknowledge 50 years from now just as no
one acknowledges now 50 years after
Tuskegee ends
that they were kind of involved and that
it was okay right
um I would just point out in passing
Claire Lehman returned to Twitter after
having stormed off months ago
um and said nothing of having been wrong
or anything like that and so anyway it
will be interesting to see if she owns
that but I think your point my point
nobody defends Tuskegee your point which
I think is exactly correct in the end
nobody's gonna be able to defend this
either because it's equally obvious how
how diabolical it is but in the present
at the moment people are gleefully still
standing by their
I don't even know what it is I was gonna
say some nasty things so people are
still
interested in shaming and destroying the
careers of people who said no
I'm actually going to think about this
scientifically and even if that's not
who you were if you just said I'm an
individual with bodily autonomy an
agency and informed consent remember
that I'm not doing it people lost jobs
people lost families people lost we were
demonized we're literally demonizing we
are still we are still being I mean our
YouTube channel still demonetized right
we don't know why we're here we clearly
have thumbs on the scale uh in multiple
platforms so this is still this is the
this is taking place in the present it's
not even the recent past
okay I'll just continue these just so
we've done them all note five no
experiment should be conducted where
there is an a priori reason to believe
that death or disabling energy uh injury
will result except perhaps in those
experiments where the experimental
physician also serve as subjects now
this one we don't know but I will eat
the Hat of your choosing if Anthony
fauci took the MRNA vaccine and I know
he will claim that he did and he will
claim that there is proof but my sense
is we know that he must have known how
dangerous that was and how useless it
was and therefore he would have been a
fool to take it but um I think
I believe that uh sensu lato reading of
number five here that is to say a broad
and generous reading of what the intent
is is that
uh if you don't know that death or
disabling injury could occur because you
didn't bother to look for that evidence
that is also a non-starter that is also
a uh a breach of the Nuremberg code and
what we know from a piece of video
released from somewhere in the European
Union I think uh in late 2022 early 2023
is a Pfizer exact being asked by um I
don't I don't remember the specifics I
think maybe a Danish
um politician yeah uh who you know who
asked for what they had found about
death and injury and the fisberg exec
said you know we didn't we didn't look
we didn't this is where the phrase uh
speed of science comes from she in that
weird uh we're working at the speed of
science what could you do
right
um so you know if if you don't
if you don't look to see if the thing
that you're then going to give to people
give to people force on people uh has
the potential for Adverse Events
and that that shouldn't actually cover
you with regard to saying well we didn't
know yes but it was your obligation to
know it was your obligation to ask the
question obviously I mean this is so
obvious and it's it is also I will just
put it here for the future because who
knows what we may one day discover but
to the extent that anybody who was
coercing the rest of us either chose to
take a different shot chose to take no
shot and no say it not say it chose to
take a special Lot number right any of
those things would indicate that this
was not only a violation of what they
should have understood but a knowing
violation right so anyway I think it is
it is a question worth asking in light
of the amount of fraud that we have seen
all right six
the degree of risk to be taken should
never exceed that determined by the
humanitarian importance of the problem
to be solved by the experiment right
all cause mortality
right it took us a long time to get
around to public discussions of all
cause mortality as the Arbiter of
whether or not this was a good idea or
wasn't
I think I can still man this one okay
which is that uh as as we understand it
SARS Kobe 2 is a very nasty virus and um
likely has long-term effects on health
and well-being that we have not yet
begun to understood because how could we
whereas the
um
you know the fatality rate is relatively
low at least if you don't have three or
more comorbidities for covid
uh it likely has long-term effects on
health
we knew that
but because they hadn't actually done
the the right tests in before launching
this product these experimental
therapy is on to the global market
we were told that they thought that this
would mitigate the effects of coping
I don't know if they ever thought that
at all they certainly didn't have the
data on which to base that thought
and
uh but if we understand that you know
covet is not a nothing Burger as some
people
particularly on the right would have you
believe it's not right it's it's a it's
a real problem in large part because it
is not zoonotic you know because it does
bring with it just this like Smorgasbord
of Frank and viral symptoms
some of which we probably don't know yet
but with regard to this was six
um
covet appeared to be
a problem
across the world at the point that the
vaccines were launched
now what we know now
is that some amount of the uh really
really immediate uh deaths and and
scourges that covid was affected coveted
was inflicting on various locations was
likely I had a heterogeneous
theatrogenic that is to say
putting people on ventilators uh
largely hastened their deaths rather
than helped them
so I'm not saying that they weren't
actually that the the they did actually
meet the standards here but is it
possible to argue that someone involved
in this could have thought that they had
with the word of six and six only I
think maybe maybe but I don't I don't
really buy it because they cheated right
they took if the if it is the case that
it is the long-term harms of covid
against which they were protecting you
then informed consent should have
allowed you to make the decision whether
or not you viewed the unknown
surrounding the treatments they were
recommending how you viewed that against
the knowns or the emerging notes I agree
but as I said I'm talking about six and
six only here right but but the point is
the humanitarian importance of the
problem they cheated two ways okay they
claimed or they let us believe that we
were actually having an epidemiological
impact they pretended that these things
blocked transmission and then they
pretended that the real concern was the
overwhelming of hospitals and that
therefore you had no right to choose
this for yourself because you were going
to end up taking up a hospital bed
neither
so this is perhaps not important but six
is about the humanitarian importance of
the problem to be solved not about the
treatment right so I don't know I'm just
responding to this one little line here
right but they knew that this didn't
solve an epidemiological problem but
that's I I don't read it that way the
degree of risk to be taken should never
exceed that determined by the
humanitarian importance of the problem
to be solved by the experiment if we
understand the humanitarian importance
of the problem to be solved as massive
Global pandemic
which is what we had been led to believe
and what we think that most of the
people who were claiming it was believed
at the time
then that is an extraordinarily High bar
that needs to be
um that that was likely you know not
passed yeah but then they would need to
have tested for transmission yes but
again not not contained within the
um
let's move on to number seven proper
preparations should be made and adequate
facilities provided to protect the
experimental subject against even remote
possibilities of injury disability or
death that would seem to preclude
gaslighting these people and running
them around with respect to whether or
not they have a known syndrome that is
Downstream of these experimental
treatments yeah eight the experiment
should be conducted only by
scientifically qualified persons the
highest degree of skill and Care should
be required through all stages of the
experiment of those who conduct or
engage in the experiment remember the
failure to aspirate uh the shadow
failure to aspirate and the offloading
of this to stadiums full of who knows
what and CVS and Walgreens and
nine during the course of the experiment
the human subject should be at Liberty
to bring the experiment to an end if he
has reached the physical or mental state
where continuation of the experiment
seems to him to be impossible you had
the right not to get another shot if you
were injured and lots of people I've
heard the story multiple times had some
terrible impact from one of the
inoculations and then we're told that
they needed to get more and you
interviewed a woman in Australia yes who
had a pre-existing condition of some
number of praises one of which included
a life-threatening allergy to one of the
ingredients in the shot to which she was
literally told that the right remedy for
was to have an EpiPen available so that
if she had an anaphylactic reaction it
could be arrested
and finally 10. during the course of the
experiment the scientist in charge must
be prepared to terminate the experiment
at any stage if he has probable cause to
believe in the exercise of good faith
Superior skill and careful judgment
required of him that the continuation of
the experiment is likely to result in
injury disability or death of the
experimental subject we are still
injecting people with these we are still
injecting young healthy people with
these yep so
that is
plausibly a violation of every single
one of the provisions of the Nuremberg
code maybe six is an exception arguably
maybe it is a violation of the two
Central components informed consent it
was not consent and it couldn't have
been informed so
and then again this is a principle that
had not been spelled out in 1947 but
doctors were held responsible for having
violated it because it should have been
obvious to them we literally hung seven
of them okay now my point is Oaths the
Hippocratic Oath the Nuremberg code
these are things that exist at a higher
level than law they are more important
and when we are violating these things
and we are violating both of those
things the Hippocratic oath and the
Nuremberg code are both being violated
we are doing harm that does not need to
be done and we are violating people's
right to inform consent
when that is happening that is the
equivalent of hearing a Mayday call
right Mayday is not a normal call to say
into the radio right you say Mayday
because there is an emergency that
requires a very special mindset right it
is the equivalent of being in an
airplane and hearing pull up pull up
right that is something telling you you
are in an emergency situation this is
not a moment for normal calculus con
cost benefit analysis this is a moment
for emergency action to save whatever
entity it is that's where we are in
history and I I'm shocked at how
remote this has been from our discussion
right it is 76 years ago but it's only
76 years ago
right this is something that should have
been on our minds
um front and center for quite some time
[Music]
foreign